good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're coming to you this
evening from rio de janeiro which is a
huge and beautiful and very complex city
on the south american coast we're going
to be here all week we're filming a
documentary for our tucker carlson
original series on the rise of chinese
power and influence in brazil brazil is
the largest economy in latin america by
far it's one of the biggest in the world
and it is the most important ally of the
united states in the western hemisphere
brazil is a big deal
and yet the biden administration seems
determined to hand brazil over
to the sphere of influence of the
chinese communist party why is that
exactly we hope to find out we'll also
be sitting down for a rare interview
with the president of brazil jr
bolsonaro soon we'll bring that to you
when we do
but first i would like to begin with the
loud and at times violent response to
the end of roe v wade that came down the
supreme court on friday as you know
if you've been following this you may
have noticed a profound change in the
way the democratic party talks about the
issue of abortion
gone is the empathy or the room for
compromise
so from the very beginning of this
debate 50 years ago even the staunchest
pro-lifer
acknowledged the anguish of young women
who are pregnant and don't want to be
who are alone and feel trapped by the
child growing inside them and that is
the reason that pro-life institutions
have built crisis pregnancy centers
and to be fair for generations even the
most committed pro-choicers acknowledge
the inherent sadness of abortion which
at the very least is the end of a
potential life
quote i do not view abortion as a choice
said joe biden as recently as 2006 i
think it's always a tragedy
and of course it always is a tragedy
even if you believe it should be legal
and democrats once said this out loud
forthrightly in fact in 1997 as white
house counsel now supreme court justice
elena kagan urged her boss bill clinton
to sign a ban on partial birth abortions
elena kagan has always been pro-choice
but ending the life of a child a week
before birth was too much even for her
and of course for his part bill clinton
never spoke about abortion as anything
but as a last resort he famously
described it as something that should be
quote safe legal and rare
our vision should be of an america
where abortion is safe and legal
but rare
you don't hear that on the left anymore
ever
in fact many on the left now behave as
if abortion is itself a positive good
excited by the fact that a child who
would have been born
wasn't
think about that for a moment
celebrating the failure of a child to
come into the world what does that say
about how you feel about children or
about people
in fact some behave as if having an
abortion is preferable to having
children
how do we know this well no on the left
encourages women to brag about having
kids
having more than a couple of children at
most is in fact is considered weird and
embarrassing something that mormons and
people who live in the ghetto do
but abortion that's something to tell
your friends about there's even a shout
your abortion campaign highly well
funded complete with perky t-shirts
bragging about ending your pregnancy
what does that say
nothing good
over the weekend you saw a lot of people
proudly shouting about their abortions
at pro-choice riots all over the country
here's what washington dc and los
angeles look like
[Applause]
we're not scared of you
what is that
the hysteria is telling
it's not the assault on bodily autonomy
of the end of roe versus wade those are
the same people who demanded vaccine
mandates but this happened all over the
country in arizona thousands of enraged
rioters tried to storm the state capital
on friday night they tore down security
fencing around the building
they pounded on the senate's glass doors
and windows while the legislature was in
session police had to fire tear gas from
the windows to protect the politicians
inside here's the state capital of
arizona looked like on friday
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
looks like insurrection to us but no
arrests were made at the arizona state
capitol on friday when that footage was
shot there will be no fbi investigation
democrats who called january 6 the
racist insurrection said nothing this
weekend about the violent siege of the
state capital of arizona did you expect
them to no of course not in fact instead
they justified it
let's be clear we have uh so many
problems with the supreme court and the
legitimacy this court has lost
legitimacy they have burned whatever
legitimacy they may still have had this
is a crisis of legitimacy and that
threatens the court's long-term
legitimacy the court is about to face
one of the largest threats to perceived
legitimacy ever in its history the
supreme court has lost legitimacy with
the american people the crisis
of the very legitimacy of the united
states supreme court
fills me with sorrow
well you got to give them credit for all
being on the same page as usual we'd
love to get the conference code to the
morning call where they set that up
but because the court did something they
don't like they're not telling us the
third branch of government is quote
illegitimate
supreme court is illegitimate because
it's allowing voters to decide what they
want to do with abortion
someone call that democracy a system in
which citizens choose their own form of
government they're telling us it's
illegitimate
on sunday the unelected governor of new
york kathy hokel explained that without
nine members the supreme court dictating
the law for hundreds of millions of
americans women are fundamentally
oppressed
because we're going to get a flood of
people i have declared this as our safe
harbor this is where we have the statue
of liberty welcoming people who are
oppressed women who cannot receive
fundamental right to control their body
or receive an abortion they are
oppressed they're welcome here in the
state of new york
so we could go on and on and play you
absurd sound bite after absurd sound
bite but what are we seeing here
it's not simply an attack an explicit
attack on the legitimacy of the third
branch of government court
it's not just an attack on the right of
people to govern themselves it's
something bigger than that what you're
seeing
is a coordinated attack
on the family and on children
people at these protests are angered
at the idea
that children are being born
watch what's happening there that is
hardly an overstatement
here's a photograph on your screen from
this weekend it was taken outside the
supreme court it shows a mother
humiliating her children in public
implying they have burned they are a
burden to her because they are still
living we saw things like this
everywhere at pro-abortion protests
often in full view of children this was
the scene for example in dallas this
weekend watch
[Applause]
so
what is that exactly what about the
thought of having children
makes these people so angry where does
an attitude like that come from
well as it turns out that attitude comes
from the same place the democratic party
now gets all of its attitudes directly
from corporate america
corporate america wants you childless
this is a big change a hundred years ago
big companies built housing for the
families of their employees and then
schools and libraries to educate them it
was the humane thing to do but it also
seemed to make good business sense at
the time if you wanted workers you could
count on you had to take care of them
and their offspring
but over time that arrangement got
expensive employees with families
demanded higher wages to support their
children and in many cases they formed
unions to get those raises so labor
costs soared
so corporate america in response to this
developed a new model hire single women
at many big companies including the
traditionally male banking sector young
women now make up the majority of new
employees and you can see why they do
they work hard they're reliable they
tend to be loyal to the companies they
work for
the one downside to hiring young women
is they can get pregnant if you're
running the hr department at citibank
that is the last thing you want children
make your health care plan more
expensive
worse than that they tend to compete
with an employee's attention
responding to after work emails seems
less pressing to most new moms than
putting their own kids to bed
that's a huge problem for big companies
so they have every incentive to prevent
their workers from having children they
can't say that out loud of course it'd
be too obvious give us the best years of
your life and in exchange we'll pay you
what's effectively a subsistence wage
and whatever overpriced urban hellscape
we're based in and then take from you
the one thing that might give your
existence meaning and joy in middle age
which is having children that's the deal
we're offering that is the deal they're
offering but they can't say that
it would sound like what it is which is
exploitation no better than what the
cotton mills once did to 14 year old
girls
so instead of saying that which is the
truth corporate america uses the
language of the social movement it
created feminism to spend the entire
arrangement as some sort of progressive
liberation movement fight the patriarchy
have an abortion it's got nothing to do
with lowering our labor costs we promise
but of course it does have everything to
do with lowering their labor cross
across the country they are making that
case abortion as liberation
many of the biggest american companies
are now paying female employees to have
abortions to end their pregnancies that
would include microsoft and apple
facebook yelp netflix comcast goldman
sachs citibank jpmorgan nike starbucks
etc etc
dick's sporting goods is offering female
employees up to four thousand dollars if
they get an abortion
does the company offer the same amount
to female employees who want to have
children
well the energy breitbart wondered that
they asked dick's sporting goods that
question but the company didn't even
respond and that tells you the answer
what's amazing is that in the face of
this so many americans who ought to know
better have fallen for it
so some accountant at a soulless
publicly traded corporation concludes
that drones with no personal lives make
cheaper workers that's what happened
but rather than question this
or resist it your average college
educated npr listener nods invigorous
bovine agreement
and then becomes completely hysterical
when someone suggests that maybe there's
another way to live
that it's at least theoretically
possible that raising your own children
might be more rewarding as a life choice
than commuting into a slum on public
transportation in order to claw your way
up to middle management at deutsche bank
but the very thought of that of turning
down deutsche bank to bring new life
into the world drives these people into
a frenzy of rage
choosing a family over service to global
capitalism that's disgusting shut up
journalist drew hernandez ran into
people like this over the weekend here's
how it went
[Music]
i guess the pandemic's over
what's wrong sir you like killing babies
you love killing babies i love killing
babies
hernandez shot the footage you just saw
he's an investigative reporter and host
of turning point usa's front lines
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight